اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى نشره
الرابعه من الرياض وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
عقب مشاورات يمنيه في الرياض مكونات
سياسيه حضرميه تعلن عن انشاء مجلس وطني في
حضرموت
مصدر رئاسي يؤكد بحث امكانياته حل النزاع
في اوكرانيا مع ولي العهد السعودي
اعتماد تصاريح الالكترونيه لدخول مكه
للحجاج لمنع حالات التحايل في نقاط الفرز
الامني
في الرابع كذلك
بعد اسبوع من التجارب نيوم تعلن نجاح
تجارب التاكسي الجوي المستخدم لاول مره في
السعوديه
الصحه السعوديه تؤكد ان العاملين خلال
المناوبات الليليه اثر عرضه للاصابه
بالامراض
حياكم الله اعلنت مكونات وقوى سياسيه
حضرميه عن تشكيل مجلس حضرموت الوطني عاقبه
مشاورات انعقدت في الرياض بمشاركه مشائخ
ووجهها واعيان محافظه حضرموت اكدت الوثيقه
الصادره عن المشاورات على وحده حضرموت وحق
ابنائها في اداره شؤونهم الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه والامنيه مؤكده ان ذلك جاء
استجابه لدعوه السعوديه بعقد مشاورات
شامله ومسؤوله تلبي تطلعات ابناء حضرموت
واشارت الوثيقه الى ان اعلان المبادئ
او ينص على تبني اليات لحمايه مصالح ابناء
المحافظه كما شددت ايضا على تعزيز القوات
المسلحه بعناصر من ابناء حضرموت ومنع
انشاء تشكيلات خارج الدوله واكدت على
التعهد بتحيد مؤسسات الدوله عن اي خلافات
تضر بالمصالح العامه والتاكيد ايضا على
الالتزامي بالاهداف المشتركه مع تحالف دعم
الشرعيه
واوضحت الوثيقه ايضا ان مجلس حضرموت
الوطني سيلتزم بوحده حضرموت واداره شؤونها
هنا في الاستوديو نشط السياسي وعضو مجلس
حضرموت المحلي عبد الله عمر بوزير حياك
الله
اهلا وسهلا فيك خلينا نحكي اولا عن
الاهميه لهذا المجلس اليوم
الاهميه في الدفع بعمليه السلام على
التراب اليمني على الاستقرار ايضا كذلك
الذي تعيشه ولو بشكل جزئي اليمن هذه
الايام
اولا
قبل اهميته على موضوع التراب اليمني
والوحده اليمنيه اهميتها بالنسبه لحضرموت
حضرموت منذ عام 19
منذ 1967
تمت عمليه
لتقليصها وابعادها عن مصدر قرار ويبقائها
مصدر
للدخل للدوله والتبوين او تمويل
ميزانيه في الدوله سواء ما قبل الوحده
وبعد الوحده
ولهذا الحضاره نتحركوا في عده منذ فتره
تقريبا عشر سنوات ولكن تحركوا على شكل
مكونات
مختلفه يعني مكون الجامعه الحضرمي مكون
المرجعيه ابناء حضرموت
والعصبه الحضرميه نحن سعينا منذ البدايه
ان لا نكون في احدى هذه المكونات وسعينا
انه لابد من وحده المجتمع الحضرمي
السياسيه والمجتمعيه والحمد لله وبعد
تواصلات كثيره على الشقه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه مختلف في
الجهات يعني ذات العلاقه
تمت دعوه هذا الوفد الى هنا وافقونا
سته اسابيع لكي نتعارف كحضاره وتم تعارفنا
وتجاربنا وبالتالي اتفقنا على توحيد ممتاز
الجميل خلني اسال ايضا عن اولويات هذا
المجلس اليوم التركيز على الاهتمام بشان
الحضرمي اولا كما قلت ايضا قبل قليل ما هي
الاليه التي سيتبعها هذا المجلس لتحقيق
الاهداف التي انشئ من اجلها اولا نحن الان
اتفقنا على على هيئه
تاسيسيه
لجنه فنيه ستقوم بعمليه اعداد اليات العمل
لمؤتمر حضرمي واسع يمكن للاخرين الذين لم
يسعفهم المشاركه في التشاورات الرياض ان
يلتحقوا الله ثم
لجنه قانونيه
واخرى للصياغه السياسيه والاعلاميه الى
اخره لاعداد وثائق هذا المؤتمر ومن ثم
نذهب الى المؤتمر
كجمعيه عموميه واسعه من مختلف الوان الطيف
السياسي والاجتماعي
لانتخاب قيادات الهيئات وايضا والحياه
القياديه لهذا المكون
لابد السياسيه
وخصوصا نحن في هذا
الاجتماعي سياسي
مطعمه سياسيه واجتماعيه البيان كما هو
امامي نص على عدم ايجاد اي تشكيلات عسكريه
خارج اطار الدوله العسكريه او امنيه هذا
الموقف هل سيبقى مقتصرا فقط على على
حضرموت ام سيشمل كل الاراضي اليمنيه انت
تعرف نحن نطالب في حضرموت الا تتم عمليه
اقامه معسكرات خارج اطار الدوله
وهنا الدوله عندنا حتى الان هي السلطه
المحليه ومجلس الرئاسه القيادي
نعم لانه في خلال الفتره الماضيه تم انشاء
عدد من الماليشيات يعني تحت مسميات مختلفه
وهذا اليوم اصبحت تشكل تحدي حتى لو وصلنا
الى التسويه ستصبح هذه الماليشيات تشكل
كبير امام استعاده الدوله نحن في حضرموت
في حديقه الامر اقل المناطق هذه تعرض لمثل
هذا الكلام فقط عندنا النخبه الحضرميه وهي
قوه عسكريه نظاميه وايضا قياداتها خريجين
كليات حربيه
واخذوا دورات اكاديميه بمعنى ان التزام
العسكري عندهم كبير فنحن لا نريد ان تتم
كانت في محاولات انا بتكلم معك بصراحه
كانت هناك محاولات لانشاء مكونات عسكريه
بالشكل هذا والمجتمع الحضرمي كان عندهم
وبالتالي لا بد من التشديد هنا في البيان
الاول
[موسيقى]
للتشاور للمجلس ان نؤكد انه لا تتم عمليه
اقامته معسكرات او خارج اطار الدوله
وايضا التنسيق مع الاشقاء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لانه احنا جينا هنا
لوضع اسس جديده لعلاقات استراتيجيه وشراكه
اقتصاديه طيب البيان ايضا يعني جاء على
ذكر بان حضرموت تتلاقى بكل مكوناتها
مع تحالف دعم الشرعيه الذي تقوده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه على اي مستوى يمكن هذا
فهم هذا التطابق هل هو على المستوى الوطني
اليمني ام ايضا سيكون على المستوى
الاقليمي ليس فقط على المستوى
القضيه نحن هنا الان نتكلم باسم حضرموت لا
نريد ان نتجاوز على الاشكه في الاقاليم
الاخرى لانه كل اقليم له خصوصياته
والمجتمع اليمني ليس مجتمعا ثقافيا واحد
لكل مجتمع ثقافته وخصوصياته الاجتماعيه
وايضا الحياتيه بالتالي لا نريد ان نفرض
على حل ولكن ان نضرب المثل للاخرين نحن
هذا ما هدفنا اليه ان نضرب المثل للاخرين
اشقائنا في في اقليم عدن او الجنوب
اشقاءنا في جنوب وسط اليمن اللي هي تعز
واب وغيرها ايضا مارب والمناطق هذه نحن
نريد ان نضرب المثل بحيث ان تكون حضرموت
اقليم قائد يستطيع ان يؤثر في الاقاليم
الاخرى لان الحضرموت لها ثقافه وخصوصيه
وخصوصا تعرف رجال الاعمال
واغلبيه اساس الجامعات ومن ابناء حضرموت
بالتالي لابد ان نضرب المثل كحظر موت ومن
ثم عمليه الاشعاع عمليه الاشعاع خصوصا وان
اجزى من اجلي منازل شبوه
والمهره حتى الان
سيتم عمليه رسم
خطه او تواصل سياسي واجتماعي معهم لتوحيد
الجهود اشكرك جزيل الشكر على حضورك معي
هنا في الاستديو ناشط السياسي وعظمه
حضرموت المحلي عبد الله عمر باوزير وانا
اشكرك جدا شكرا للعربيه وايضا اريد من هذا
المكان انه قدم الشكر الكبير
لكل مسؤول في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ساهم معنا في هذا العمل شكرا جزيلا لك
حياك الله
قال مصر رئاسيون فرنسي بان بلاده ستبحث مع
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
امكانيات حل النزاع في اوكرانيا المصدر
الرئاسي الفرنسيه كاد ايضا ان القمه ستكون
مناسبه للنقاش مع السعوديه حول موضوع
الانتقال نحو الطاقه وتعزيز التعاون في
هذا المجال بالاضافه الى مجالات اخرى بين
الشركات الفرنسيه والسعوديه التي يمكنها
ان تعمل معا خصوصا في مجال التقنيات
الحديثه والانتاج الصناعي
من الجبيل ينضم الينا عضو مجلس الشورى
السعودي والمحلل الاقتصادي فضل البعوني
سيد فضل حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض خلينا نحكي بدايه عن القمه من اجل
ميثاق عالمي جديد والتي ستعقد في باريس
خلال هذه الزياره التي يقوم بها الامير
محمد بن سلمان الى فرنسا ما الذي يمكن ان
تقدمه هذه القمه واهميه هذه القمه ايضا
على المستوى المالي العالمي اولا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طبعا هدف القمه هو
خلق نظام مالي جديد اكثر عدلا وتضامنا
لمواجهه التحديات العالميه ومنها ازمه
الديون ازمه الفقر المتغيرات التغير
المناخي التنوع البيئي ايضا تحقيق التنميه
المستدامه في الدول الناميه بشكل عام
نعتقد ان تركيزها على ملفين اساسيين الاول
مالي مرتبط
بالديون السياديه وكل ما له علاقه بتنظيم
النظام المالي العالمي وخلق نظام مالي
عالمي جديد والجانب الاخر هو الشق بيئي
مرتبط بالتغير المناخي وتاثير التغير
المناخي على الاقتصاد العالم الاقتصاديات
الدول بما يؤثر على
قدرتها على سداد ديونها نعم ممتاز هل يمكن
ان تعالج هذه القمه المشكله ربما الاهم او
الاكبر في في هذه في هذه القمه ولكن من
اجلها يعني اجتمع المؤتمرون وهي الديون
السياديه للدول خصوصا بعد ازمه كوفي 19
بعد ازمه او خلال واثناء ازمه التضخم
العالمي التي نعيشها اليوم
طبعا هناك تحديات كبرى حقيقه بدات منذ عام
2008 وازمه الديون العقاريه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وما تبعها من الازمه
ماليه ثم اقتصاديه عالميه ثم بعد ذلك تم
معالجتها جزئيا ولم تشفى يشفى النظام
المالي العالمي منها ثم انتقلنا الى جائحه
كورونا وما تبعه ايضا من تحمل الدول
المديونيات كبرى وانفاق توسعي كبير على
النظام الصحي الانظمه الصحيه بشكل عام
ومواجهه الجائحه ثم انقطاع سلاسل الامداد
وتوقف الانتاج وكل هذا اثر سلبا على
الاقتصاد العالمي اليوم نحن امام ازمه
اخرى مرتبطه ايضا بالديون السياديه
البريطانيه اعلنت اليوم ان الدين العام
تجاوز حجم الاقتصاد العالمي وهنا اول
الاقتصاد البريطاني عفوا لاول مره منذ
العام 1961 ايضا لدينا التضخم العالمي
واسره على اسعار الفائده وارتفاع وهذا
يؤثر سلبا على الاقتصاد العالم كل هناك
ازمات وليس ازمه يواجه النظام المالي
العالمي بما يستدعي وجود مثل هذه الازمات
طبعا العالميه قبل قليل مصر رئاسي فرنسي
ذكر بان السعوديه ستلعب دورا مهما من اجل
ميثاق عالمي جديد لمعالجه هذه الازمات
التي ذكرت اي دور يمكن ان تلعبه السعوديه
في هذه القمه برايك هذا الدور الهامه التي
وصفته الرئاسه الفرنسيه طبعا هذا التصريح
اعتمادا على الدور الهام الذي لعبته
السعوديه في العام 2008 وما حققته في حفظ
النظام المالي العالم والاقتصاد العالمي
بجهودها في مجالين مستقلين ثلاث مجالات
الاول مرتبط بالملف النفطي وتاثيره على
النمو العالمي وبالتالي حافظه المملكه على
نموا
جيدا للاقتصاد العالم ومعالجه مشكلاته
الجانب الثاني هو ما يتعلق بضخ
الاستثمارات العالميه ود
الجانب الثالث وهو ما يتعلق بتجربه
المملكه مع نظامها المالي الاكثر كفاءه
عالميا حتى من بين مجموعه العشرين
وبالتالي تنعكس تجربتها على الاخرين اليوم
في هذه القمه يكفي ان يرا السمو ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان وفدا عاليا المستوى
للمشاركه في هذه القمه ما يعني ان المملكه
توجه نظرها لمعالجه هذه المشكله وان تساهم
مساهمه كبيره من جانبين مالي اقتصادي
استثماري يعني العنوان ربما البارز ايضا
حتى في هذه القمه هو وضع قواعد لنظام
عالمي جديد هل يعني ذلك بان النظام المالي
العالمي الذي نعيشه اليوم لم يعد
يعني قادرا على تحمل التبعات الاقتصاديه
التي تلت كل الازمات التي مررنا فيها
والتي نمر فيها الان لذلك هناك قواعد
جديده لهذا النظام المالي العالمي باختصار
شديد نعم لولا هذه الازمات والتحديات لما
دعي لهذه القمه نعتقد ان العالم مقبل على
ازمه حقيقيه مرتبطه بالديون السياديه التي
وصلت مستوى لا يمكن معالجتها اضافه الى
ضعف النمو في الدول الناميه واتساع مشكله
الفقر في جميع الدول واذا اضفنا الى ذلك
الحرب الحاليه روسيا واوكرانيا وما قد
يترتب عليها من مشكلات كبرى عالميه
فبالتالي نحن امام ازمات وليس ازمه ومن
المهم معالجه هذه الازمات من خلال وضع
قواعد لعبه جديد في النظام المالي العالمي
ونعتقد ان هذه القمه عملها سيكون مهما
لتحقيق هذه الاهداف ولكن السؤال الاهم هل
تلتزم الدول الكبرى بما تضعه على طاوله
المباحثات وتتفق عليه لا اعتقد ذلك لان
الدول الكبرى ومقدمها لانه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والدول الاوروبيه اول
من يخلق هذه المعاهدات متى ما كانت
مصلحتها ضد هذه الاتفاقيات التي تم وضعها
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك لم يتبقى لدي الكثير من
الوقت سيد فضل البوعنان عضو مجلس الشورى
السعودي والمحلل الاقتصادي من الجبيل شكرا
جزيلا لك
اذا استعرضت السعوديه مشاهدينا يوم امس في
باريس خططها لاستضافه اكسبو 2020 وذلك
امام مكتب المعارض الدولي حيث كشفت
السعوديه عن رصد نحو ثمانيه مليارات دولار
لاستضافه تلك المناسبه المزيد مع زميل
العنود العبدلي
العلم
تكتب الدولي للمعارض في باريس
رياض اكسبو 2020 ومن المقرر ان تكون
مشاهدينا كل استعدادات اكسبو 2020 جاهزه
بحلول فبراير من العام 2020
بحسب الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه الملكيه
لمدينه الرياض المهندس ابراهيم بن محمد
السلطان وسيكون موقع اكس ومشاهدينا معتمدا
على الطاقه النظيفه ويراعي المعايير
البيئيه كما اضاف انه من المتوقع ان
تستضيف السعوديه اكثر من 120 مليون زائر
في عام 2030 استضافه السعوديه لمعرض اكس
ومشاهدينا تتلائم مع بيئه الاستثمار التي
وصفها وزير الاستثمار السعودي المهندس
خالد الفالح بالله محدوده وحول الميزانيه
المخصصه لاستضافه حدث اكسبو مشاهدينا كشف
الفالح بانها تبلغ 7 مليارات و800 مليون
دولار
الاستثمار باكثر من ثلاثه ترليون و300
مليار دولار امريكي في المملكه بنهايه
العقد الحالي كما ان ميزانيه اكسبو الرياض
ستكون سبعه مليارات و800 مليون دولار
تكون المعرض مشاهدينا ملتقا عالميا لشركات
للبحث عن فرص في السعوديه كما ستقدم
مواردها وامكاناتها لانجاح مختبر استثمار
العالمي السعوديه ستكون مركزا لمختلف
الثقافات كما تعتبر الرياض وجهه سياحيه
عالميا لذلك فان الرياض ملتزمه بتنظيم
افضل نسخه من مؤتمر اكسبو عبر تاريخه حسب
ما افادت به الاميره ريما بنت بندر موضحه
انه سيتم توفير تاشيره خاصه لحضور
اكسبورياض 2030 والذي سيركز على التواصل
والشموريه مع جميع الثقافات
نحن ملتزمون بتنظيم افضل نسخه من مؤتمر
اكسبو عبر تاريخه لاجل العالم
كما اشارت الاميره ريما بنت بندر الى ان
السعوديه تشهد قصصا استثنائيه عظيمه مشيره
ان رياض تغيرت في الثماني سنوات الماضيه
اكثر مما حصل في الثمانين عاما الماضيه
مدير مكتب العربيه في باريس حسين قنيبر
حسين مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشاط
الرابع من الرياض مصدر رئاسي فرنسيه تحدث
عن
الدور ولي العهد السعودي في
يعني هذه القمه التي ستعقد في باريس من
اجل ميثاق مالي عالمي جديد
الدور ايضا كذلك حتى السعودي في
يعني اخماد الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه ما
الذي اتى به هذا المصدر من جديد
اهلا بك نايف نعم الفرنسيون على مستوى
الرئاسه يقولون انه من المهم جدا ان تشارك
السعوديه في هذه القمه الماليه العالميه
التي ستنعقد في باريس غدا وبعد غدا
بمشاركه حوالي خمسين رئيس دوله ورئيس
حكومه وعدد كبير من وزراء يمثلون دولائهم
ومن ممثلي المجتمع المدني بهدف مناقشه عده
مسارات من بينها مكافحه الفقر وايضا السير
نحو الانتقال البيئي ومواجهه التحديات
المناخيه وايضا تعزيز التنوع البيولوجي
يقول المصدر الرئاسي الفرنسي ان هذه القمه
ستكون مناسبه لجمع اقطاب عالميين مهمين
اقتصاديا انها مناسبه لتجمع هذا التحالف
الاقتصادي المالي العالمي ومن ضمنه
السعوديه يقول هذا المصدر بهدف خلق صدمه
ماليه عالميه تتمثل اولا في تعزيز العمل
من اجل مكافحه الفقر من جهه ومن جهه ثانيه
تعزيز العمل من اجل ضمان انتقال بيئي يكون
عادلا قدر الامكان سنحاول ان يكون عادلا
يقول المصدر الرئاسي الفرنسي ايضا ان
التعاون بين الشركات السعوديه والفرنسيه
ستكون هذه القمه مناسبه لتعزيزه في مجال
الانتاج الصناعي وفي مجال التقنيات
الحديثه وكما تعرفون قال المصدر الرئاسي
الفرنسي متوجها الى عدد محدود جدا من
الصحفيين كنا من بينهم كما تعرفون ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان مهتم
بكل هذه المسارات اي مواجهه التحديات
المناخيه وايضا قياده الانتقال البيئي
وايضا العمل على تعزيز التنوع البيولوجي
وتعزيز التعاون بين السعوديه وعدد من
الشركاء من بينهم فرنسا على مستوى الانت
قال نحو الطاقه كل ذلك سيكون جزءا مما
سيناقش خلال القمه الماليه العالميه ستكون
قمه ماليه لكن لها طابع ايضا سياسي ولها
جوانب اخرى كثيره ايضا الرئاسه الفرنسيه
ماذا ذكرت على المستوى السياسي حسين
تماما تقول ان السعوديه تلعب دورا مهما او
تتحمل مسؤوليه كبيره لناحيه مساعدتنا على
ايجاد مخرج سريع من الازمه في اوكرانيا
لان لهذه الازمه تداعيات ماليه واقتصاديه
على العالم باسره بما في ذلك على الشرق
الاوسط
وننتظر من السعوديه ان تلعب دورا في اتجاه
دفع روسيا الى
الشروع في محادثات سلام تنهي الازمه
الاوكرانيه من هنا اهميه مشاركه السعوديه
في هذه القمه الماليه العالميه لان تسريع
ايجاد حل الازمه في اوكرانيا هو في مصلحه
كل دول العالم بمن فيها دول الجنوب وبمن
فيها تحديدا السعوديه فقال هذا المصدر
الرئاسي الفرنسي نايف اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
باريس مدير مكتب العربيه حسين قنيبر شكرا
جزيلا لك
الرابعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل ايضا
بعد توجيه نيابه السعوديه القبض على شخصين
اساءا في محتوى مرئي لاحد الوافدين
حياكم الله من جديد انهت منظومه النقل
السعوديه استعداداتها لموسم حج هذا العام
وذلك لتسهيل التنقلات اكثر من مليوني حاج
بين المشاعر والحرم المكي باستخدام قطار
المشاعر والحافلات ووسائل نقل جديده
تستخدم لاول مره في الحج بمسارات مخصصه
[موسيقى]
من مشعري منها يلتحق بنا مراسل العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي عدم حسين مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
كيف هي الصوره من مشعر منها الاستعدادات
حتى اللحظه التي رصدتها عبد المحسن
عبد المحسن هل تسمعني طيب يبدو اننا نواجه
مشكله في الاتصال مع الزميل عبد المحسن
سنعود اليه حالا ما جهز هذا الاتصال من
مشعل من مره اخرى اذا وفي ذات الملف
مشاهدينا شدد الامن العام السعودي على عدم
الاستجابه للاعلانات المضلله بغرض النصب
والاحتيال عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لتقديم خدمات عده منها اداء فريضه الحج عن
الاخرين وتامين الاضاحي ووسائل النقل
مؤكدا ايضا على تطبيق العقوبات النظاميه
بحق المخالفين
كشفت مصادر العربيه في السعوديه عن انخفاض
نسبه الغاء حجوزات الحجاج من الداخل منذ
الاول من الشهر الهجري الجاري حيث وصلت
تقريبا الى واحد في المئه بعد تطبيق
المرحله الاخيره من سياسه الغاء حجوزات
حجاج الداخلي موسم 1444 والتي تتضمن حسم
مئه في المئه من قيمه العقد مصادرنا افادت
ايضا بان
الشركات السعوديه استبدلت التصاريح
المطبوعه بالتصاريح الالكترونيه منعا
للتحايل على نقاط الفرز على مداخل مكه
اعود مره اخرى الى الزميل عبد المحسن
الحربي من مشعري منى عبد المحسن حياك الله
معي مجددا في نشره الرابعه تسمعني الان
بشكل واضح
نعم اسمعك نايف اهلا وسهلا فيك
الاستعدادات في ميناء كيف رصدتها حتى الان
بالفعل مع وصول اكثر من مليون و350 الف
حاج رسميا وصلوا الى مكه المكرمه وتوجهوا
لاداء طواف القدوم ومن ثم الاستراحه في
مساكنهم في مختلف مناطق مكه يستعدون خلال
الايام القادمه الى الانتقال الى المشاعر
المقدسه وتحديدا المشعر منها ومن ثم
الانتقال الى عرفات ومزدلفه والعوده الى
منى في رحله متواصله تقوم عليها او يكون
تنقلهم من خلالها عبر وسائل متعدده هذه
العام سيكون هنالك استخدام لوسائل جديده
في حج هذا العام حيث نتحدث بالاضافه الى
قطار المشاعر الذي يتواجد بالقرب منه حيث
يحتوي على
تسعه محطات ثلاثه محطات في منى وثلاثه
محطات في مزدلفه وثلاث اخريات في عرفات
وهذا هذا القطار قد او حقق ارقام كبيره
خلال الاعوام الماضيه حيث نقل في عام 2019
مليونين و300 الف راكب وذلك عبر
2270 رحله وتوقف بسبب جائحه كورونا لعام
لعام 2020 خلال العام الماضي فقط نقل هذا
القطار مليون
وخمسه وثلاثين الف راك
كيف هذا العام سيكون هناك استخدام لوسائل
نقل جديده نتحدث عن للمره الاولى العام
الماضي كان هنالك تطبيق
لاستخدام
السكوترات تحديدا بين المشاعر هذا العام
سيتم التوسع بها بمقدار 1000 سكوتر سيكون
هنالك سكوتر
لاستخدام الفردي وسكوتر لاستخدام الثنائي
والثلاثي والرباعي وهنالك مسار مخصص له ما
بين منى والحرم المكي مسافه المسافه ما
بين من والحرم المكي خلال ثمانيه دقائق
بالاضافه الى استخدام مركبات ذاتيه
القياده للمره الاولى في الحج وبالاضافه
الى تسخير كافه الامكانيات تحدث حتى عن
الدرونز يتم استخدامها لرصد المنافذ منافذ
مكه المكرمه ورصد
ازدحامات المروريه
كافه المعلومات التي تتيح لكافه
العاملين في الحج على تسهيل مرور المركبات
والحافلات بشكل امن اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
كل هذه المعلومات كل هذه التفاصيل من مشعر
مينا مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
شكرا جزيلا لك
وانضم الي ايضا من جده نائب رئيس اللجنه
الوطنيه للحج والعمره سابقا عبد القادر
الجبرتي سيد عبد القادر
حياك الله معي في نشات الرابعه من الرياض
قبل قليل كان الخبر يتحدث عن انخفاض نسبه
الغاء الحجوزات خليني احكي اولا بشكل سريع
على هذه السياسه سياسه الغاء الحجوزات
المطبقه هذا العام كيف رصدتوها ابرز
الارقام المهمه عنها يعني بشكل سريع
طيب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله اولا اشكر لكم
تسليط الضوء على هذا الموضوع لانه هو
موضوع الساعه وموضوع عامل اساسي للنجاح
تخطيط دوله كامله في انجاع هذا الحج
الدوله ما قصرت بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى
يعني رصدت كل اجهزتها لنجاح هذا الموسم
الالغاءات
لبعض الحجاج للاسف الشديد الذين يظنون انه
ممكن بطباعه هذا التصريح الورقي يمرون بان
نقاط التفتيش بات بالفشل افشل الامنيه
بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى باعتمادها
البطاقه الرقميه خلينا نقول للناس خلينا
نقول للناس انه انه كيف تصير هذه العمليه
عمليه التحايل
بالتصاريح بالدخول ايضا الى المشاعر
المقدسه بالدخول ايضا الى
كذلك الى مكه المكرمه في اوقات الحج كيف
تم هذه العمليه
طيب السؤال وجيه جدا العمليه ببساطه يسجل
الحاجه النظامي
عبر القنوات الرسميه
ويدفع المبلغ ثم يحصل على التصريح ويطبعه
بعد كده يلغي يضحي بواحد في المياه من
قيمه الالغاء او نسبه 10% من المبلغ على
على ظن سيمر من المبلغ هو اللي تفعل شركه
الحج اللي كان حيروح يعني معاها الدفع
الدفع بالكامل هذه
السياسه وزاره الحج بداتها من اعوام سابقه
وهذا العام
اكدت هذا الموضوع التسجيل بالكامل من
صلاحيه وزاره الحج
والسداد المبالغ لوزاره الحج ما في اي
صلاحيه لاي شركه للتسجيل وهذا كمان يعني
يسلط الضوء انه اتصال الحجاج الذي لم
يسجلوا الحج بالشركات لا يفيدهم
التسجيل عبر القنوات الرسميه لوزاره الحج
اللي هي البوابه المسار الالكتروني او نسك
وبالتالي هذه التصاريح اللي كانوا
يستخدموها اول للتحايل والدخول الى مكه
بعد ما يلغوا
موجوده اليوم ابدا الان ما صلاحيه الان
الان يعرض نفسه لل
جزائر
للدخول الى مكه الان الطريقه
السليم بشكل نظامي ويحصل في
تطبيق نسرق على البطاقه الرقميه
الفعاله التي تظهر للنقاط التفتيش انها
فعاله اما بغير هذا سيعود
ويتحمل الجزاءات ممتاز خليني اتكلم على
على نقطه كمان ايضا مهمه هذا العام هو في
باقات اقتصاديه اسعارها مخفضه يعني كما
ذكر وخدمات جديده ايضا لشركات الحج
الداخليه وش هالباقات الاقتصاديه وكيف
اقبال الناس ايضا حتى عليها بما انك يعني
احد الممارسين في هذا القطاع طيب الدوله
ما قصرت وزاره الحج
بتخطط من اليوم الاول لعوده الحجاج الى ان
تصدر السماح بالتسجيل عبر المسار
الالكتروني وتنشيء من الباقات في متناول
كل
الفئات
البرنامج الاقتصادي عمل لفئه لا تستطيع
ميزانيه في الدفع لكن على على الحاج
المواطن والمقيم ان يخطط الحجه ان يخطط
الحج حتى يعرف اعلان البدء
بالتسجيل ثم يسجل في الباقه المناسبه له
مثل ما يخطط لدخول ولده في المدرسه
علي انه يخطط تماما لا
تنتاب
الرغبه في الحج في وقت متاخر ثم يبحث ثم
يجد من يحتال عليه ويفقد
كثير من الاموال
ان شاء الله
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات عن
المشاركه معي من جدا الرئيس اللجنه
الوطنيه للحج والعمره سابقا عبد القادر
الجبرتي
وفي الحج ايضا كشف وكيل وزاره الحج
والعمره لشؤون الحج عايض الغين من العربيه
عن وصولي 1,350 الف حاج من جميع منافذ
المملكه مؤكدا جاهزيه الخدمات والخطط
التشغيليه للحج
وصل الى مكه المكرمه حتى اليوم قرابه
مليون و350 الف حاج من جميع المنافذ
البريه والجويه والبحريه
ونحمد الله عز وجل قاموا بتقديم اداء نسك
طواف القدوم وتوجهوا الى مساكنهم في مكه
المكرمه بكل يسر وسهوله تم تقديم اكثر من
820 باقه خدمه مختلفه تضمن توفير جميع
الخدمات التي تلبي رغبات وتفضيلات والحجاج
اعلنت شرطه منطقه مكه المكرمه القبضه على
شخصين لاساءتهما لاخر عبر محتوى مرئي وكان
نائب العام سعود المعجب قد وجه بالقبض
عليهما وذلك بظهور احدهما متنكرا بزي
النسائي اثناء وجودهما في المركبه وتوثيق
فعلهما ونشره ما من شانه المساس بالاداب
العامه وحرمه الحياه الخاصه
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو المستشار
القانوني والمحكم القضائي محمد الوهيبي
حياك الله بعمريض
[موسيقى]
قانونيا وش بعدها
القبض وبعد هذا التوجيه ايضا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على اشرف الانبياء والمرسلين
نبينا محمد واله وصحبه وسلم يعني بدايه
هذا المقطع لا يمثلنكجتمع سعودي باي شكل
من الاشكال وهي تعتبر يعني اخطاء فرديه او
تجاوزات حدثت من الاشخاص بس كلمني بالشرق
القانوني اول شيء وش راح
تكون العقوبه لمثل هذا الفعل تمام طبعا
الفعل هذا دخل في نظام مكافحه الجرائم
المعلوماتيه ودخل ايضا في نظام مكافحه
التحرش ليش لانهم قاموا بارتكاب ثلاثه
افعال جميعها مجرمه وفقا للنظامين الفعل
الاول التشهير انهم قاموا بالتصوير والنشر
هذا يعتبر تشهير بالشخص اللقاء اللي تم
تصويره ونشر المقطع الخاص فيه واذا كان
موافق حتى وان كان موافق لا يعتد القبول
او برضاء المجني عليه في ارتكاب اي جريمه
يحق للتنازل عن الحق الخاص او المطالبه
بالحق الخاص ولكن الحق العام وفقا للنظام
لا يعتد باي شيء واذا كان موافق واذا كان
موافق يكون متهم يكون متهم اذا كان موافق
في الفعل نفسه فالفعل او في نشره او في
نشره اي طبعا اذا كان في نشره وكان مخالف
للاداب العامه مثل ما احنا شفناه طبعا
يعتبر شريك في كلهم شركاء
ممتاز هذا لو افترضنا ان هناك قبول من
الشخص ولكن حسب ما شفنا في المقاطع ترى ما
كان فيه قبول من الشخص هذا الامر الاول
اللي هو التشهير من الامر الثاني طبعا هذا
وفق للماده الثالثه من نظام مكافحه
الجرائب المعلوماتيه الامر الثاني اللي هو
وفقا للماده السادسه من نظام مكافحه
الجرائم المعلوماتيه التي نصت على انتاجنا
من شانه المساس بنظام العام والاداب العام
طبعا المقطع كان يمس بالاداب العامه لانه
كان يوحي ببعض الايحاءات الخاصه باقامه
علاقه
غير شرعيه
وايضا التشبه بالنساء تشبه الرجل بالنساء
والى اخره الامر الثالث وهو يعد مخالفه
لنظام مكافحه التحرش
ليش لو نرجع للمقطع ونطلع عليه سنجد انه
المقطع كان فيه بعض
الايحاءات الجنسيه طبعا نظام مكافحه
التحرش قال لك اي فعل او قول
ذو مدلول دوم مدلولا جنسيا فهو يعتبر
جريمه تحرش طبعا ان شاء الله ما حد يرجع
يشوفه يعني
التصرف اللي حصل هو مستوى مستوى هبط جدا
ليش تتكرر مثل هذه المقاطع مؤخرا قصص
المقالب
يعني ما فيها محددات للاداب للذوق العام
وش الهدف منها او ليش يروحون لهذا الاتجاه
هل هو بحث سريع عن عن الشهره حتى لو
اضطررت يعني انك تتشبه بالجنس الاخر حتى
لو اضطررت انك تضر بالحياه والحرمه الخاصه
لحياه شخص اخر ايش تفسيرك
انعدام اخلاقي هذا اولا يعني اللي يقوم
بمثل هذه الافعال انا اعتقد انه يعني لا
يمتلك حتى اساسيات اخلاقيه او سلوكيات
سويه الامر الاخر والامر الثاني واللي انا
يعني اتمنى بالفعل ان يكون بشكل كبير جدا
من الجهات طبعا شكرا للنيابه العامه سرعه
تفاعلها خاصه الاشخاص القائمين على الرصد
النيابي ولكن نتمنى بالفعل ان يكون هناك
تشهير لاصحاب هذه المقاطع لو كان في تشهير
لاصحاب هذه المقاطع او تشهير بالاحكام
لتقع عليهم تتوقع ان نسبه الوعي حترتفع
حيكون في رادع في خوف نسبه الردع سترتفع
نسبه الوعي موجوده
المجتمع السعودي خاصه اصبح يعلم ما هو
الصح من الخطا نظاما جميع القطاعات وزاره
العدل النيابه العامه وزاره الداخليه انتم
كاعلاميين ايضا لكم دور كبير جدا في
التوعيه وكلنا نتلمس التوعيه وموجود لا
يوجد شخص يعني الا ما ندر انه يجهل انه
مثل هذه الافعال النيابه كل فتره
تعلن او تشهر ايضا حتى
باصحاب هذه الفيديوهات لنفس الطريقه يعني
بحيث انه اذا انتشر الفيديو يتم الاعلان
بانه تم التوجيه بالقبض على هؤلاء الاشخاص
ويكون معروف ومشارين اساسا في وجه الاشخاص
اللي موجودين فبالتالي المساله هنا انه ما
في خلينا نقول ردعه والتعاب من الناس لما
تشوف نفس القصص تتكرر او نفس المقالب يعني
هذا اللي على اساس انها مقالب يعني
انها جالسه تتكرر ما في ردع وفي تكرار
لنفس هذه القصص او المقالب او الفيديوهات
المخالفه للاداب وللذوق العام او او غيره
وين الخلل وين المشكله الخلل ما هو في
الرجع مثل ما قلت لك يعني هناك عقوبات
وتكون عقوبات صارمه يعني انت يعني يعني هل
تعلم كم تقريبا العقوبات التي هؤلاء
الاشخاص وفق النظام
مكافحه الجرائم المعلوماتيه عندك الماده
الثالثه تصل الى سنه سجن وغرامه الى 500
الف ريال الماده السادسه الى خمس سنوات
سجن التحرش الى سنتين لو خذينا يعني
تقريبا الحد الادنى من كل واحده منها لنقل
عن اربع سنوات سجن كفيله باضاعه مستقبلك
بمجرد ايش مقطع لا يتجاوز دقيقتين وهذا
اللي احنا دائما نقوله مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مجرد تغريده لا تتجاوز سطر او
سطرين او مقطع فيديو لا يتجاوز دقيقه الى
دقيقتين كفيل بانه ينهي مستقبلك لانك انت
تكون اعتديت على اشخاص اعتدت على حرمتهم
لهؤلاء الاشخاص حتى وان كان ذلك باستخدام
معرفات وهميه يعني الحمد لله ترى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تمتلك في القطاع الامني
قوه هائله جدا في القدره على الوصول
للاشخاص
وهميه خلاص اشكرك جزيل الشكر على حضورك
معي هنا في نشره الرابعه المستشار
القانوني ومحاكم القضائي محمد الوه يبي
شكرا جزي
لا الرابعه مستمره تتابعون فيها بعد قليل
يوم تعلنوا نجاح تجارب التاكسي الجوي
المستخدم لاول مره في السعوديه
حياكم الله من جديد في السعوديه اعلنت
نيوم وشركه فولوكوبتر عن استكمالهما بنجاح
سلسله تجارب التاكسي الجوي وذلك للمره
الاولى في السعوديه نيوم كشفت ايضا بان
سلسله التجارب استمرت مده اسبوع كامل وذلك
بعد فتره التعاون لمده ثمانيه عشر شهرا 18
شهرا مع شركه فولوكوبتر المزيد مع الزميله
عنود العبدلي
اعط قفزه جديده في مجال النقل المتطور
اعلنت شركه نيو استكمال تجارب رحلات
مركبات الكهربائيه العموديه
كاول شبكه عامه لتنقل الكهربائي العمودي
في نيوم المشروع الذي سيضم ايضا خدمه
التاكسي الجوي سيكون بشراكه مع شركه
فولوكوبتر الالمانيه التي ستقوم شركه نيو
معها بانتاج مروحيات النقل الجوي حيث قامت
شركه نيوم بطلب خمسه عشر عشره طائره من
ترازي فولك هوبتر لبدء عمليات الطيران
الاوليه خلال عامين الى ثلاثه اعوام مقبله
الطائره من طراز فولو الالمانيه هي من
احدث الطائرات متعدده المروحيات من الجيل
الرابع بحيث تعمل بالطاقه الكهربائيه وهي
مطوره تقنيا ولديها ميزه ميزه القدره على
اقلاع والهبوطي عموديا وفق معايير الطيران
الحديثه ومتطلباته فهذه المروحيه مشاهدينا
تم تصميمها وفقا لمعايير تلبيه سلامه
المحدده من قبل وكاله الطيران الاوروبيه
وتضم تعليقات المستخدمين بالاضافه الى
بيانات الاختبار من جميع اجيال المروحيات
السابقه
مع نطاق محسوب يبلغ 35 كيلو متر وسرعه
جويه تبلغ
210 كيلومترات في الساعه حيث تم تصميمها
لتكون بمثابه تاكسي جويا داخل المدينه عند
الطلب ويبلغ وزنها مشاهدينا الاقصى عند
الاقلاع 600 كيلو جرام
وما يميزها مشاهدينا هو التصميم الايقوني
مع الخطوط الانسيابيه والتكنولوجيه
المتطوره جدا والتي تم اعتمادها من طرف
الشركه الالمانيه المشروع الجديد يندرج
ضمن منظومه يوم للتنقل العام متعدد
الوسائط والخالي من الانبعاثات الحادثه
الى تطوير النظام تنقلين عام تراثي
الابعاد بالكامل وانشاء اول منظومه تنقل
مستدامه ومتكامله والانشاء نظام بيئي
متكامل للتنقل
اكدت وزاره الصحه السعوديه عبر احد حسابات
على تويتر وجود رابط بين النوم والجهاز
المناعي حيث قالت انه بعد الكشف على
موظفين نوبات العمل الليليه او مناوبات
العمل الليليه ظهرت الكشوفات انهم كانوا
اكثر عرضه للاصابه بالامراض وذلك ما يؤكد
ان حرمنا الجسم من النوم لفترات طويله
يمكن ان يضعف الجهاز المناعي
تنضم الي هنا في الاستوديو الاستشاريه
طبيبه الاسره الدكتوره الامير ابراهيم
دكتور حياك الله معك الله يسلمك
هل صحيح انه اللي ما يزين يومة ما يزين
جهاز المناعي المناعي
يعني حرمان الشخص من النوم ممكن يعادل او
نفس تاثير الكحول ايوه فيكون عنده القدره
على الاتزان العضلي والعقلي يتاثر فيها
سواء مثل القرارات القياده مثل لو انه
الشخص انه طبيعه عمله يطلب انه حركه
الجراحين على سبيل المثال او حتى الاطباء
للطلب شغلهم او حتى طبعا ممارسه الصحي
بشكل عام يعني نتكلم عنها التاثير على
الجهاز المناعي هي مساله نقص النوم يعني
عندنا اضطرابات النوم مختلفه في انواع
كثيره عندك الارق مثلا اللي هو الشخص
النبي يجلس على الفراشه ولا بيجيه النوم
في عندك شيء يسمونه تخفيق اللي هو الشخص
اللي ما تشوف كذا نام في اي مكان مكان عام
على السياره بنام وهذا خطير طبعا الناس
اللي انها تنام وهي تسوق سياره عندك حالات
ايضا من الارق اللي انه ما ينام نهائيا
لانه موجوده فيها هذه ايضا وفي عندك لحاله
يعني هذا الشخص انه يكون يصحى من النوم او
ما يقدر ينام وانه يحس ان رجلينا تتحرك في
عندك ايضا الكوابيس
[موسيقى]
بقول لك اياها بالنسبه للاضطرابات النوم
التاثير على الجهاز المناعي احنا لما ننام
نوم عميق فتره طويله جسمنا بيدخل في مرحله
يعني اعاده التنظيم مثل لما انك تشحن
جوالك او مثل الاجهزه انها تهدا فيها فهذه
المرحله هي تساعد على بالنسبه للاطفال
تساعدهم على النمو بشكل افضل بالنسبه لمن
لديه الجروح او حتى اللي عنده مشاكل
مناعيه انت لو مثلا لاحظت المرضى اللي
عندهم امراض فيروسيه ايش يقول لك فيه يقول
لك انا طول اليوم تعبان واحاول اني انام
بالعكس من مصلحه الدكتوره نوم ليش انا ما
انام مثلا في وقت مبكر ليش انت ما تنامي
في وقت مبكره والزملاء اللي موجودين احنا
سوينا قبل شوي يعني مسح سريع عليهم ما حدا
ينام بدري ما حدا السبب مش قضيه انك تنام
بدري او ما تنام بدري زي ما تفضلت انه في
ناس طبيعه عملها ما تنام في الليل مثلا
رغم انه يفضل النوم في الليل هي موضوع عدم
الاكتفاء من ساعات النوم على مدى الاسبوع
المفروض ينام الشخص في الاسبوع يتفاوت
بالعمر وحسب الجنس فلو احنا
يعني ممكن حتى من ست ساعات يا ثمان ساعات
وممكن ناس ينام اكثر يعني الاطفال يناموا
12 ساعه كبار السن بيناموا ست ساعات اربعه
الى ست ساعات هي القضيه الكواليتي يعني
جوده النوم يعني فرضا انك انت نمت 12 ساعه
بتشوف لمرضى اضطرابات النوم يقول لك انا
طول اليوم نايم لكن يصحى تعبان ومجهد وما
عنده طاقه وايضا مناعتها متاثره لان النوم
اللي عنده ما في جوده نوم كل شويه بيصحى
كل شويه بالنسبه للنومه بيتقلب بشكل مستمر
وبعدين نبحث عن جوده النوم لا لا هي ما هي
كل
علاقه يعني وانا بقول لك مثال
انك انت فيهم تنام اربع ساعات او ممكن
يكون عندك جت انك مسافر فنومك تاثر فيها
تاخذ يوم في الاسبوع تسحب نوم طول اليوم
انك ترتاح فيها عوضت الاسبوع هي مساله ان
هي تعوضها ان يكون عندك جوده نوم المشكله
لما يكون بشكل مستمر بشكل مستمر كل مره
نومك قليل نومك قليل او جوده النوم سيئه
هنا حتتراكم عليك من ناحيه الصحه من ناحيه
المناعه من ناحيه المناعه من ناحيه
القدرات التركيز العقليه
يعني القدره على التركيز بشكل عام من
ناحيه ايضا الا وحتى المزاج تحسن المزاج
دكتور انا ما عاد عندي القدره على اني
اكمل هالاحوار معك للوقت خلص شكرا جزيلا
لك يعطيك العافيه موضوع النوم هو تخصص
يعني ان شاء الله الله ان شاء الله عاد
يعني
وفي
معلوماتك ممتازه
الاسره الدكتوره لمياء ابراهيم الله يسلمك
يعطيك العافيه
اعقبه مشاورات يمنيه في الرياض مكونات
سياسيه حضرميه تعلن عن انشاء مجلس وطنيين
في حضرموت
مصدر رئاسيون فرنسي اؤكدوا بحثه امكانياتي
حل النزاع في اوكرانيا مع ولي العهد
السعودي
اعتمد التصاريح الالكترونيه لدخول مكه
للحجاج لمنع حالات التحايل في نقاط فرز
الامني
وبعد اسبوع من التجارب نيوم تعلن عن نجاح
التجارب التاكس الجوي المستخدم لاول مره
في السعوديه
الرابعه انتهت شكرا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات